[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le magazine européen de la
rédaction de tv 78 certains sont
déboussolés d'autres transporté
l'expression l'expérience atypique du
concert jardinage de l'association puce
muse ne laisse personne indifférent ses
concerts mélange virtualité et réalité
et sont notamment rendues possibles
grâce à des instruments ultra modernes
nous avons pu assister à l'une de ses
représentations à paris reportage dédié
aux fonds européens
surprenant dans quelques instants
l'entrepreneuriat se conjuguent de plus
en plus au féminin malgré des idées
reçues et stéréotypes encore tenaces les
choses évoluer notamment en ile de
france nous recevrons dans cette
émission deux entrepreneuses ancien
lauréat du concours créatrice d'avenir
un concours régional financé en partie
par les fonds européens un marché
européen qui dure depuis un mois les
négociations post élections européennes
se poursuivent entre les chefs d'état et
les institutions continentales en jeu
les principales présidence des plus
hautes fonctions politiques de l'union
européenne et l'influencent aussi de
chacun des pays nous dire à patrick
martin geniez spécialiste des questions
européennes et administrateur de la
maison jean monnet située dans les
yvelines
[Musique]
c'est donc avec une expérience pour le
moins étonnante que l'on débute cette
émission une expérience musicale avec
l'association puce muse un centre de
création de musique visuelle qui
bénéficient de fonds européens assis
dans des transats puce muse propose des
concerts jardinot dans les parc
francilien
pour ce faire le musicien et compositeur
serge de l'aubier utilisent des méta
instruments reportage au parc montsouris
à paris
c'est un concert où la star est la
surprise surprises sonores d'abord
surprise instrumental ensuite les
concerts de puce muse ont pour but de
transporter le spectateur dans un
ailleurs et si je retrouve tout ce que
j'aime dans le monde
mais l'effet principal pour moi et
apaisant extrêmement apaisant relaxant
et enveloppants d'abord on comprend pas
effectivement que la vibration puissent
venir d'un siège banal et on comprend
pas bien non plus au chic man 2
le musicien ce qu'il veut faire avec
chebah net pour bien comprendre
l'intérêt du concert jardinage il faut
se laisser aller s'asseoir dans un
transat vibrant tête posée sur la
structure mais surtout il faut savoir
écouter le musicien et interprète serge
de l'aube il
comme ça on écoute et une écoute à ses
proches finalement d'une ce qu on
pourrait supposer être une écoute
intra-utérine serre avant la naissance
on entend avant de mettre ça on le sait
on sait pas très bien comment on sait
que les oreilles arrive plus tôt à la
fin du développement
il est très probable qu'on met une
conduction osseuse de son mélange de
bruits naturels abeilles aux tempêtes
mais aussi de bruit virtuel cette
alliance sonore n'est rendue possible
que grâce à des années de recherches
pour concevoir des instruments que l'on
croirait tout droit sorti d'un film de
super héros qui ne va pas le des méta
instrument c'est un méta instruments et
en fait sa mesure tout voilà sa mesure
les gestes que je fais comme ça et si
gras ou ici où est ce que je suis
en
pour ces recherches et création puce
muse bénéficie notamment de 700000 euros
de fonds européens
les spectateurs assistent gratuitement à
l'original concert jardinage soutenir
les projets innovants en matière de
développement régional c'est l'ambition
du concours région star proposer chaque
année par la commission européenne pour
l'édition 2010 9,5 projets franciliens
sont en lice dans différentes catégories
parmi eux la start up carnot computing
que nous avions reçues en marche sur ce
plateau et qui propose rappelez-vous de
chauffer les habitats grâce aux calculs
informatiques
le prix du public sera décerné vous
pouvez voter jusqu'au 9 juillet prochain
sur internet et de concours il en est
également question avec les deux invités
qui viennent de nous rejoindre en
plateau gwendoline co 13 bonsoir et
leslie marelle bonsoir bonsoir à tout
les deux vous êtes lauréate du concours
créatrice d'avenir organisé par
initiative d'île de france
gwendoline c'est et en 2015 dans la
catégorie innovation solidaire grâce à
mauves à domme et leslie vous étiez l'an
dernier dans la catégorie innovation
pour bio mme harel on va parler de
chacun de vos projets bien sûr mais
commençons déjà par expliquer ce qu'est
ce ce concours créatrice d'avenir si
j'ai bien compris c'est un dispositif a
réservé aux femmes qui se lancent dans
l'entrepreunariat en ile de france vous
confirmez gwendoline et bien ça
exactement c'est vraiment réservé aux
femmes qui sont dirigeants d'entreprises
dans la région parisienne
d'accord vous vous êtes lancé pour
quelle raison par exemple les styles
comment s'est fait le cheminement est ce
qu'on est venu vers vous est ce que
c'est vous qui vous êtes lancé tout seul
alors créatrice à venir je l' ai
découvert sur internet qu'on cherchait
effectivement des financements ou
manière de faire connaître la société
qui n'avez pas encore créé mais j'avais
déjà le dispositif et en regardant
effectivement des concours j'ai vu que
créatrice d'avenir donc récompenser des
femmes entrepreneures et je trouvais ça
très intéressante dit pas autant y aller
donc quand j'étais prête à créer la
société g
l'appel qui correspondent alors on
précise que les inscriptions au concours
2010 9 sont ouvertes de plus le 1er juin
et se poursuivre jusqu'au 30 septembre
prochain
ce genre de concours d'initiative est ce
que c'est encore essentiel selon vous
qui avez l'expérience qui est on va dire
sur le terrain tous les jours les idées
reçues les clichés sont encore très
présents aujourd'hui en ile-de-france en
france généralement sur
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin
alors je vends ma propre expérience oui
effectivement il ya encore quelques
clichés très on va dire très robuste qui
est de la femme qui va entreprendre mais
comment va-t-elle conjuguer l'emploi et
sa vie de famille des enfants chose
comme ça ces choses que j ai moi reçu
comme si vous allez voir des banquiers
car je suis aussi d'aller voir sa
besoins des organismes
on m'a dit vous avez moins de 30 ans et
si jamais vous voulez avoir des enfants
comment vous faites
j'ai pas très bien compris la question
sachant que j'ai déjà un film ça ne m'a
pas empêché d'entreprendre mais je leur
ai laissé le luxe de rester dans leur
cliché mais c'est dommage il y en a
encore et c'est pour ça que le concours
créatrice dernière est intéressant parce
que ça montre qu'il ya énormément de
d'entreprises sont gérées par des femmes
et dans des domaines des femmes peuvent
surprendre
et ça ne m'empêche pas d'être d'être des
femmes averti tant professionnellement
que personnellement one doligé que vous
partagez cet avis est ce que vous aussi
vous avez le droit à ce type de remarque
un peu désobligeantes aux journées eut
dépassé moal directeur mi journée
c'était la secrétaire donc évidemment
après on essaye de passer outre tout ça
les chiffres sur l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin se sont pas très beau par contre
les chiffres de robustesse de ces
entreprises sont très bons donc je pense
qu'il ya des choses à faire
est-ce que vous avez des conseils à
donner à celles qui nous écoutent
regardent et qui voudraient se lancer ce
que c'est fait pour tout le monde ce
type de concours par exemple moi je
pense qu'il faut il faut pas hésiter il
faut regarder si on correspond
dans les secteurs dits des modalités
d'amphibiens sortie qui t'a fait voilà
mais hormis cela je perds tu veux pas
hésité à se lancer parce que ça coûte
rien et on va pas perdre on va gagner 2
restons visibilité si on est finaliste
et deuxièmement on quelqu'un qui va
revoir notre projet va y croire
donc ça donne aussi beaucoup d'espoirs
pour les entrepreneurs qui des phases
disent pas non mais ça va pas
fonctionner donc c'est d'abord une
expérience un retour de professionnels
de gens qui s'y connaissent
c'est vraiment lors du jury ça a été
quelque chose de très important de
pouvoir avoir toute une série de
personnes très très experts dans leur
domaine qui donnait des conseils et qui
jugeait le projet et c'est vrai qu'on
est on est vraiment très fier quand on
arrive à chaque étape du concours c'est
très agréable
leslie mara l'on va parler de votre
entreprise qui propose un service
d'accompagnement pour le déménagement
des seniors et des percées
je me suis trompé c'est gai wan doline
oui je suis conduit dans l'est dans les
deux langues
gwendoline cortès vous c'est pour le
déménagement des personnes en situation
d'handicap mais surtout les seniors
concrètement quels services vous offrez
à ces personnes là alors nous notre
objectif c'est vraiment d'accompagner le
changement de domicile des seniors
on se rencontre souvent que les
personnes âgées habitent dans des
logements qui ne leur sont pas forcément
adapté aussi bien en termes physiques
que favorisant le lien social dont des
logements éloigné du centre-ville des
logements qui vont être au grand et nous
notre objectif c'est de les aider à
changer de vie en les aidant à trier
leurs affaires en étant là le jour du
déménagement et ensuite on recréant leur
univers donc là du début jusqu'à la fin
du déménagement à z notre petite mamie
va vraiment être complètement fou foot
est accompagné dans toutes les étapes de
son déménager pour ceux qui seraient
intéressés évidemment il ya le site
internet qui va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran
du coup les slits marelle j'ai bien les
bonnes informations je me suis emmêlé
les pinceaux
vous aussi c'est pour les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment mais
vous n'êtes plus tournée vers les
technologies puisque vous proposer un
dispositif électronique qui permet j'ai
lu votre site internet d'utiliser le
visage pour contrôler les outils type
ordinateurs et tablettes commencent à se
matérialiser concrètement alors c'est un
dispositif donc électronique vraiment
pas plus grand que ça qu'on va ça qu'on
va pouvoir mettre sur une lunette ou sur
incertaine sur ne porte pas de lunettes
et ça va détecter donc les mouvements de
tête pour déplacer la souris sur
l'ordinateur ou la tablette ou le
smartphone et on va permettre de cliquer
donc soit avec le sourcil soit le soufre
sur le menton l'idée est de proposer une
solution complète donc on a le choix
entre le déplacement donc du dispositif
de la souris et de cliquer comme vous
aimons cliquer sur une souris avec une
zone de leur visage parce que ces
personnes en génération dans un handicap
très lourd donc elles ne peuvent pas
bouger la main comme vous et moi donc
idée de leur donner un minimum
d'autonomie et utiliser la technologie
qu'on utilise tous les jours ça va
bientôt s'adapte aussi sur les liseuses
donc on va pouvoir leur permettre aussi
d'avoir accès à la culture qui leur est
souvent un petit peu restreint de très
beaux projets pour toutes les deux merci
merci d'être venus sur sur ce plateau
merci pour vos réponses et bravo aussi
pour vos projets innovants et votre
ancien prix pour celles et ceux celles
plus tôt qui seraient intéressés par le
concours créatrice d'avenir le site
internet affiche vos écrans aussi
créatrice d'avenir point com merci
encore lui aussi a façonné et continue
de façonner l'avenir européen le
programme erasmus a été lancée
officiellement il y a à 32 ans c'était
en juin 1987 il a permis bien sûr à des
millions de jeunes européens de
découvrir le continent et ces pays
depuis quelques années il s'est élargi
oc
un nouveau public les précisions de
philippe le guen coordinateur pour le
parlement européen de la maison jean
monnet basée dans les yvelines
c'est quand même un des plus anciens
programmes européens qui existent même
si au démarrage ça a été quand même un
petit peu laborieux c'est à dire que
l'idée de 2
de faire circuler des étudiants pour des
périodes de formation de cours dans
différents pays alors à l'époque y en
avait que 12 aujourd'hui
il ya même plus de pays que deux pays de
l'union européenne puisque les pays
candidats et des pays mêmes comme la
norvège ou le liechtenstein sont
éligibles au programme erasmus donc on
voit que ça a beaucoup évolué mais ça
paraît toujours été facile parce qu'on
se heurte elle aa au domaine des études
donc universitaires des diplômes qui est
du ressort des systèmes nationaux donc
harmoniser les diplômes on en n'était
déjà pas là mais faire que correspondre
des périodes de
de six mois de semestre dans les
différents systèmes pour les faire
valider aujourd'hui ça paraît naturel
avec le système qui existe mais qui a
été très long à mettre en place et au
départ c'était une véritable révolution
au fil des années le programme a été
élargi et aujourd'hui s'appelle erasmus
plus et il est ouvert à d'autres jeunes
en qualifications apprentissage
formation professionnelle écoles aussi
il est ouvert aux écoles secondaires au
lycée et c'est un des principes
fondamentaux de l'europe c'est la
mobilité et la le croit mais rasmus et
1/3 de mobilité on se déplace soit avec
sa classe soit seul dans un autre état
membre
on y passe un séjour assez long on y
étudie peut-être dans une langue qui
n'est pas la sienne
donc ça représente vraiment le l'idée de
d'europe tels que vous les gens monnaie
nous ne connaissons pas des états unis
sont des sommes donc là on est en train
d'unir en effet toute une jeunesse et
cette union d'ailleurs des fois des
bouches même sur des unions
matrimoniales ou même sur des bébés
puisqu'on en a dit qu'il y avait plus
d'un million de bébés asmus en europe
donc c'est peut-être une anecdote en
tout cas c'est une réalité c'est à dire
que les jeunes circulent plus se
rencontrent ceux qui en bénéficient sont
changés effectivement sans doute ensuite
dans leur for intérieur ils deviennent
beaucoup plus européen d'avoir vécu une
période longue dans un autre pays on
devient ont soi même on est on est
changée
[Musique]
deuxième partie de cette émission nous
sommes à présent en compagnie de patrick
martin geniez bonsoir vous êtes un
spécialiste des questions européennes
enseignants notamment à sciences po
paris aux auteurs de l'ouvragé l'europe
at elle un avenir aux éditions studyrama
est aussi administrateur de
l'association jean monnet située dans
les yvelines avec laquelle nous avons
l'habitude de travailler pour cette
émission nous sommes désormais un mois
tout juste après les résultats des
élections européennes l'actualité et
l'intérêt des médias pour le sujet est
forcément un peu retombée pourtant
l'activité politique
elle est importante à bruxelles pour
résumer aujourd'hui on est rentré dans
une phase de bord en marche et les
parlementaires européens cherchent à se
placer dans des commissions et surtout
les chefs de gouvernement et c'est à eux
de s'entendre sur des nominations pour
les postes-clés est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un peu nous éclairer sur
cette phase politique
concrètement oui c'est tout à fait
important nous avons des élections vous
savez que cette année c'était les 40 ans
de l'élection du parlement européen au
suffrage universel direct et donc il est
tout à fait normal car l'issue de ces
élections on cherche de personnalité
pour diriger l'europe car il n'y a pas
que le parlement européen
il a également l'élection au poste
stratégique vous avez évoqué le marché
le fameux mercato c'est à dire que
plusieurs pauses doit être renouvelée et
le principal de ces postes est bien
évidemment celui de président de la
commission européenne et vous savez que
ça suscite un certain nombre de
difficultés compte tenu du fait que les
chefs d'état ne sont pas nécessairement
d'accord avec le parlement européen
et d'ailleurs cela va faire l'objet
d'intenses tractations ce week-end
puisque il ya le g20 à tokyo et les
chefs de gouvernement européens vont se
concerter et dimanche se réunit à
bruxelles un conseil extraordinaire pour
essayer de se mettre d'accord sur un nom
si il ya eu déjà un premier conseil le
20 et 21 juin pas d'entente sur les noms
en résumé il ya le président de la
commission européenne qui doit être
choisi la présidence du parlement du
conseil de la banque centrale européenne
mais aussi du haut représentant pour les
affaires étrangères vous vous parliez
des règles qu'elles sont justement les
règles à respecter les équilibres à
sauvegarder eh bien vous savez que
d'abord le président ou la présidente du
parlement européen dépend de la majorité
donc ça c'est la sphère du parlement
européen la chef d'état et de
gouvernement n'ont rien à y voir
s'agissant des autres postes et bien
effectivement les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont leur mot à dire je dois
même plus que leur mot à dire sur le
dessin du président de la commission
européenne et de la personnalité doit
être désigné par le conseil européen des
chefs d'état de gouvernement mais le
traité a prévu que c'est bien le
parlement européen qui élit le président
ou la présidente de la commission
européenne doit il y avoir un équilibre
sachant qu'aujourd'hui au niveau du
parlement vous avez dû en parler dans
vos émissions
il n'y a pas de majorité pour un seul
groupe puisque majorité d'allemands
auparavant et depuis 40 ans on se
répartissaient des postes entre les
démocrates-chrétiens le ppe et les
socialistes et aujourd'hui avec la
montée des populistes nationalistes ils
ont une capacité de nuisance
les partis traditionnels ont vu leur
nombre de députés diminué on a un groupe
centriste qui représente plus de 100
députés et les verts qui ont grimpé ce
qui fait que aujourd'hui d'autres
parties peuvent éventuellement envisager
la présidence du parlement au vert tout
cas ça complique
l'élection du président de la commission
européenne et vous avez vu qu'il bagnols
macron n'était pas d'accord avec le
candidat proposé par l'allemagne wilkie
et manfred weber avant de parler des
noms concrètement quel est l'intérêt des
états que pour eux le but c'est de
mettre le plus de personnes de leur
nationalité pour ensuite peser sur les
politiques européennes où finalement ça
se passe à un autre niveau
alors comme l'a dit présent la
république française il ne s'agit pas de
placer systématiquement des
personnalités de son pays mais en
coulisses naturellement on se bat pour
cela faut pas se cacher les yeux on sait
très bien qu'aujourd'hui par exemple le
secrétaire général du parlement européen
et un allemand
le secrétaire-général de la commission
européenne est un allemand tant que
certains ne voient pas d'un bon oeil le
fait que le futur président de la
commission européenne puisse est un
allemand
et force est de constater hélas même si
on n'est pas là pour se battre en
fonction des personnalités que la france
n'a pas exercé de responsabilités
majeures depuis très longtemps nous
n'avons pas eu de président de la
commission européenne jacques delors qui
était un excellent président de la
commission européenne
nous n'avons pas eu deux présidentes de
parlement européen depuis 2000 avec
madame fontaine et par conséquent nous
avons eu un président de la banque
centrale européenne jean-claude trichet
mais nous n'avons pas eu de
responsabilités essentielles et
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est important
éventuellement de pouvoir dire via la
france c'est un grand pays elle doit
pouvoir exercer des responsabilités
mais aujourd'hui on ne voit toujours pas
pointé au bout de la ligne en quelque
sorte un candidat français sauf si
michel barnier ventre j'allais justement
évoqué michel barnier pour prendre la
tête de la commission on en parlait
initialement c'était manfred weber le
tête de liste de la droite européenne
qui était censé prendre la tête de la
commission selon selon les règles en
place depuis 2014 aujourd'hui il n'est
plus favori à rien en tout cas il semble
plus favori à rien ce que vous confirmez
déjà et est ce que du coup michel
barnier qui négocie en ce moment le
break site est devenu le nouveau favori
alors man show de rêveurs en effet n'est
plus la personnalité qui est pressenti
puisque le parlement européen a dit lui
même qu'il ne voulait pas il n'y a pas
de majorité pour un truc bieber la
france ne voulait pas qu'ils suscitent
pas un certain nombre de revenus en
allemagne en ce moment vous avez vu
déclarations récentes de certaines
personnalités politiques
quant à michel barnier il s'était retiré
en quelque sorte au profit de ma très
sévère mais du fait que man show des
verts n'est plus le candidat désigné
il revient en quelque sorte sur le tapis
et tout le monde dit à bruxelles qu'il
rêve d'être président de la commission
européenne
donc ça peut être en effet un candidat
de compromis mais pas ceux chances sont
assez faible dans la mesure où dès lors
que la france a retoqué le candidat
allemand
il ya peu de chances que l'allemagne
soutienne un candidat français le 30
juin donc cessé dimanche les chefs
d'état vont devoir se retrouver
concrètement très rapidement et ce qu il
pourrait ne pas y avoir de décisions qui
soient prises de 30 juin prochain que ya
pas de négociation qui aboutissent à nos
deals en fait un peu comme comme le
bruxisme et cette fois ci sur les sur
les postes clés oui il ne faut pas
l'exclure mais il ya toutes les
munitions siècle parlement européen sur
unis début juillet et le 16 juillet
normalement en réunion
hier du parlement européen doit désigner
donc le futur d'abord première un peu
comme la bauxite on a su pousser aussi
parce qu est ce qui pourrait arriver la
même chose pour les postes clés je pense
il ne faut pas exclure un blocage vu que
la france a été très dure vis-à-vis de
manfred weber
il ya même certains des propos méprisant
vis-à-vis de m haies d'honneur on a dit
qu'ils étaient incompétents timide
remontée de charisme du charisme des
tops politique et cela est très mal
passée en allemagne où donc à député
responsable à céder ou de ses souhaits
au parlement a dit d'emmanuel macron
qu'il était entièrement voire
révisionnistes et qu'il allait détruire
la démocratie européenne donc on a
vraiment un affrontement qui n'est plus
cacher aujourd'hui qui fait que cet
affrontement entre la france et
l'allemagne risque en effet de bloquer
la nomination d'anne ont en tout cas ça
compromet les chances selon moi d'un
candidat français un mot encore sur sur
l' influence française mis à mal on a
l'impression depuis depuis quelques
jours avec cette affaire autour de
nathalie loiseau et des propos qu'elle a
tenus devant des journalistes français
en off comme on dit dans le jargon
médiatique mais qui sont sortis après
coup par un journaliste belge est ce que
ça ça peut vraiment porté un coup
justement aux ambitions françaises au
parlement européen où alors ce ne sont
que des affaires qui intéressent va dire
le petit milieu médiatique et politique
européen je crois que ça a apporté pour
être franc et objectif a sacré coup à
l'affluence de la france au sein du
parlement européen et par que chez pour
la nomination poste exécutif madame
loizeau n'a pas du tout été à droite en
stigmatisant ses collègues y compris
fond c'est d'ailleurs tout le monde en a
pris pour son grade
résultat des courses n'a pas pu être élu
à la tête de son groupe politique alors
que cette place que c'est pour avoir de
place notamment des présidences de
commissions ce que c'est un argument qui
tient la route
ou alors c'est une porte une porte de
secours un peu flou je pense que ça ne
tient pas du tout la route
elle aurait dû être conciliant vis-à-vis
de tout le monde elle aurait été élu
président du groupe et le fait d'être
président ou présidente de groupe vous
donne accès à la présidence des groupes
parlementaires et donc à la conférence
des présidents du parlement autun et là
vous avez du pouvoir et donc là elle ne
l'a pas eue cet art
qui était lui tant mieux pour la
roumanie et alors que se pose il est
très francophile c'est très bien d'avoir
des gens qui sont francophiles
mais ce n'est pas la france c'est à dire
que l'on n'est pas d'abord défendre les
intérêts de la roumanie moi même si on a
une approche assez francophile et
européennes au coach k la france pour
l'instant et bien n'a plus de position
de force et cela affaiblit en quelque
sorte la position d' emmanuel macron au
sein du conseil européen pour conclure
un mot on est obligé d'en parler du du
bric site aujourd'hui c'est toujours le
flou complet le break site doit être
acté le 31 octobre prochain aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas encore de premier ministre
en grande-bretagne depuis la démission
de theresa may boris johnson tient la
corde quand même visiblement lui qui
n'est pas partisan d'un break site on va
dire d'où en tout cas est ce que ça joue
aujourd'hui sur sur sur la politique
européenne encore ce break si puisqu'on
en a moins parlé
est-ce que ça va revenir en force peser
encore sur sur l'avenir européen
bien sûr pas qu'on n'aura pas réglé
cette histoire de votre site on pourra
pas aller plus loin sur la voie de
l'union européenne l'approfondissement
de l'union européenne et il semblerait
que bree johnson malgré tous ses
déboires conjugaux
vous avez pu constater et bien et bien
partie parce que les trois quarts des
militants du parti conservateur veulent
véritablement le bric sites au 31
octobre qu'il est bien parti pour être
premier ministre et naturel est bien
parti aussi pour avoir un break site le
31 octobre puisque lui l'affirmé y aura
pris 6 kilos 31 octobre
voilà sauf s'ils devaient être
remboursées en verser quelques jours
après puisqu'il n'a plus de majorité à
la chambre des communes
donc évidemment que ça va impacter la
vie de l'union européenne jusqu'à ce que
cette affaire soit soldé merci patrick
martin geniez d'être venu sur notre
plateau et pour pour vos réponses et
éclairage je rappelle que vous êtes
notamment enseignant à sciences po paris
et auteur de l'ouvragé l'europe at elle
un avenir aux éditions studyrama c'est
une promesse de campagne d'emmanuel
macron le service national universel a
débuté mi juin pour deux mille jeunes en
france l'objectif notamment et de
renforcer la cohésion nationale et de
développer une culture de l'engagement
un tel dispositif existe t-il ailleurs
en europe chez nos voisins comparaison
continentale avec olivier chanut ex
responsable du centre d'information
europe direct de
saint germain en laye au niveau de
l'union européenne le service militaire
existe encore dans certains pays par
exemple à chypre avec un service
militaire qui dure quatorze mois
on a aussi le cas en grèce avec un
service militaire qui dure entre neuf et
douze mois
on a par exemple le danemark avec un
service militaire de quatre mois on a
aussi la finlande avec un service
militaire au minimum de 165 jours à la
lituanie ce par exemple avec un service
militaire de neuf mois et on peut aussi
citer par exemple la suède avec une
petite particularité parce que là le
service militaire concerne à la fois les
hommes et les femmes avec une durée de
12 mois certains pays comme la suède et
la lituanie ont décidé de réintroduire
le service militaire quand on regarde
pourquoi ils ont décidé de le
réintroduire on se rend compte que c'est
surtout à cause des tensions
géopolitiques notamment avec le voisin
russe
afin de répondre aux problèmes soulevés
notamment par les objecteurs de
conscience certains pays ont décidé
d'offrir une alternative au service
militaire qui correspond concrètement à
un service civil est donc on retrouve
notamment cette possibilité par exemple
en autriche en finlande en grèce ou à
chypre
en règle générale ce service civil va
être un peu plus long que le service
militaire est concrètement en termes de
missions qui vont être effectués ça va
principalement être démission par
exemple au sein d'associations ou de
collectivités territoriales afin
d'effectuer des missions d'intérêt
public
c'est la fin de ce set 8 europe prochain
et dernier numéro de la saison le 12
juillet 12 juillet prochain merci à tous
et à très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]